los sindicatos a las calles en argentina
es la primera vez que lo hacen desde que
el presidente alberto fernández llegó al
poder en 2019
también protestaron movimientos sociales
denuncian que los salarios están por
debajo del valor de la canasta básica
argentina para tener un panorama
bastante claro es privilegio comer ante
la inflación interanual en argentina que
es del 46 2% los manifestantes reclaman
más ayudas del estado aunque el déficit
ha sido responsable del incremento
inflacionario pero la pobreza situada en
un 37 por ciento en 2021 aumenta por lo
que en las calles han pedido la
aprobación de un ingreso básico
universal este representante del
movimiento obrero explicó los motivos de
la marcha
e
los salarios no alcanzan
la remarcación de precios realmente la
seguridad no argentina
los analistas creen que la inflación
puede llegar al 90 por ciento a fin de
año además del déficit influye el hecho
de haber tenido tres ministros de
economía en un mes la devaluación del
peso y una crisis cambiaria que
dificulta las importaciones
argentinas tiene un acuerdo de 44 mil
millones de dólares con el fmi ya han
empezado a tomar medidas como reducir
subsidios y elevar facturas de servicios
de luz gas y agua afectando al bolsillo
del consumidor y en medio de
manifestaciones cada vez más habituales